a hotel that calls itself the first
cannabis-friendly hotel in Las Vegas is
going to open next week thanks for
staying with us here at 6 30 I'm Denise
Valdez and I'm Brian Loftus but there
are some questions whether smoking pot
patrons will be actually breaking the
law eight news now reporter Joshua
peguero digs deeper and has the answers
the Lexi opens on June 2nd owners
describe it as a hotel where you can
smoke marijuana inside their rooms but
after we spoke with state and local
agencies those going to that hotel for
that reason may want to know the rules
the Cannabis compliance board tells me
the Lexi doesn't hold any type of
cannabis license and the hotel hasn't
contacted them about its plans as for
the city of Las Vegas the Lexi hasn't
applied for a cannabis consumption
Lounge license which wouldn't even be an
option since it is within 1500 feet of
Palace Station Nevada did pass a
consumption Lounge law but there are
certain restrictions
one of the big ones is you can't be
within 1500 feet of gaming unless it was
in cannabis establishment that was
grandfathered in the Lexi was formerly
The Artisan attorney Amanda Connor says
an issue is where the hotel patrons will
break the law by smoking inside their
rooms I think it comes down to is the a
hotel room a public place or a private
place because by Nevada law you can only
consume in a private place unless the
one exception being unless that business
has a consumption Lounge license here's
a response from Lexi quote the Lexi
operates in accordance with all local
and state laws no cannabis will be sold
on the property no cannabis can be
legally delivered to the property and
smoking in common areas is prohibited by
law end quote they go on to say guests
can only smoke on the fourth floor which
amendocano says operates in a legal gray
area I think most people would argue
that hotel rooms are public places
they're open for business for public to
rent those rooms I asked Lexi why people
can only smoke on the fourth floor and I
also ask them if the rates will be
different if they stay in other rooms
I'm still waiting for them to respond
we're putting your Sahara on the 15th
Joshua paguero eight news now